the only regret that I have is that we
couldn't do more because guess what
after America did pull out Isis took
Ramadi and when they got in her body and
we had friends that were there
Isis went and found the families that
had worked with coalition forces
prevalently and they murdered about five
hundred families so that sickens my
heart that that's horrible so when you
hear that politically it sort of gets
back to overtime at earlier that you
know when they say all right well we're
gonna get out this day like it so it's
got to be over we got to end this thing
we got to get out to say and you know
that that's counter to what you've
learned sort of on the ground that's
just got to be the worst thing you could
hear yeah one of the work even if you
don't want a conflict to continue first
of all there's no one that wants
conflict less yeah then the people that
have to go and fight it right when when
we sign up for a war it's my friends
yeah and and not just my friends but
it's the military that's gonna go out
and die when we sign up oh there's a
conflict we need to take care of so yes
we don't want to go to war if you go to
war you go to war to win in the
situation that happened in Iraq we
pulled out completely there was not
there was no one that had fought in Iraq
that thought oh good call that's a great
call
there was embers of the inserts the
insurgency had been had been all but
crushed but it had not been completely
extinguished and there were members of
insurgents that were there and as soon
as we pulled out they started groaning
that's what turned into Isis yeah so
that's that's around 2008 ish right yeah
but like that so then what what is sort
of a more sensible way of leaving
something so you could you do a certain
amount of cleanup let's say and you
freeze some of these cities and and good
things have happened but you don't want
to be there forever how do you manage
that and with the stresses of just the
political machinations and all that
stuff yeah I mean that's that's
something that you have to look at every
situation that you're in
and you have to say okay well what can
we do here how how much can we draw down
our troops and it's not it's not a
certain amount of time it's not a
certain amount of troops
you you have to look at each situation
and do an assessment and figure out the
best way to move forward and guess what
you won't you won't be perfect and and
that's why an absolute thing like hey
we're just gonna we're not going to do
this anymore is is a risky move so what
do you think's go so like when Obama did
that what do you think his military
leaders who I'm sure you probably
respect some of them or maybe even know
some of them what do you think they were
telling him that because it's so counter
to what you're laying out here I'm sure
they told them this is not a good idea
this is not a good idea there's like I
said there's no one that had spent time
on the ground in Iraq that said oh you
know what we're good let's leave because
it was still a very very fragile
situation yeah and it looked good it
looked good on paper but you have to
give the the the civilian populace
enough time to really kind of figure out
how to live this way because it's a new
way to live yeah
you're oppressed under Saddam then
you're oppressed under some insurgency
and to have that be lifted and then say
okay we look around it's gonna take some
time to figure out how we're going to do
this and we needed to provide them with
enough security and stabilization that
they could and it's not like we were
working hard the last few Alif who wrote
the book books with me he deployed in
2010 I want to say they had so what
while I was in Ramadi there was a guy
wounded or killed almost every day for
the six months I'm here there was a guy
wounded or killed almost every day in
Ramadi sometimes two sometimes five
sometimes seven sometimes one when Lafe
went back to allah mark ramen so al
ahmar province that the the province
that Ramadi is the capital of in his
six-month deployment there was one
fatality for all of coalition forces and
it was from a vehicle rolled over Wow
so it was it wasn't like we were over
there gutting it out anymore with the
insurgents the insurgents had been
really really suppressed and we just
needed to give the the locals enough
time to kind of put things together and
start to move forward become stable you
politically stable economically stable
and that is what we should have done do
you think it's our moral responsibility
to do actions like this if we can help
people that are living in these horrible
situations that that morally and that we
I mean we the United States have to do
it I think that we have to weigh the
morality of taking care of other people
and taking care of our own people right
so when you and this is a very difficult
decision to make and something I've
talked about on my podcast was the
genocide in Rwanda so the genocide in
Rwanda happened and there was 800,000
Tutsis that were killed by Hutus in a
hundred days so this is more efficient
than Hitler was able to pull off and by
the way most of the killing was done 98%
of the killing was done with machetes so
this was just crazy when that was
happening I was sitting off the coast
with a in a sealed platoon on a ship
with a bunch of Marines a bunch of Navy
power and we could have gone in there
and done something and we did and I
would say that the primary reason that
we didn't is because a year earlier
Black Hawk Down had happened and we lost
a bunch of servicemembers in Somalia and
so I was like hmm you know what we don't
really want to get involved in that
again and so that's that what we have to
weigh is we have to weigh what are we
willing to lose in order to save someone
else and then what do we benefit from
saving those people and is that benefit
worth the the expense in money and lives
that we invest into it and sure some of
that benefit is feeling like we can look
ourselves in the mirror as a country
that's part of the benefit part of the
benefit might sure there's economic
benefit sure there's political benefit
but part of the benefit is can we look
in the mirror and say you know what we
almost a million people were butchered
in this country and we didn't do
anything about it that's something that
we have to contend with and that's why
these decisions are hard to make and and
when you do make these commitments as a
country then you need to commit
and not go half-hearted into these
efforts if you're gonna if you're gonna
risk American lives you better be doing
it for a reason that is that merits
putting our men and women at risk what
do you make of the catch-22 that America
is in with this dilemma all the time
where it's like if we don't do anything
no one does it but then every time we do
do something there's always the
unintended consequences and how long do
we have to be there and everything else
it's really it's a it's a strange
bargain that America's sort of put in or
or put itself in well yeah then this is
this is we started off this conversation
talking about leadership and why
leadership is so hard
leadership is hard because decisions
it's not two plus two equals four it's
it's it's not that at all there's this
insane amount of calculus and and
secondary and tertiary things that
happen after you make a move that you
think is good this is what makes it so
hard and that's why you know for America
as the leader of the free world
guess what being in that leadership
position it's a hard position to be in
and and guess what just like a leader
just like when I was a leader when I was
a leader of a SEAL team when I was the
leader of a SEAL task unit did I do
everything perfect absolutely not
I've made mistakes I made mistakes I
made mistakes where people died and that
is the burden of leadership that you
bear and so as a nation we're in the
same situation the things that we do we
are not going to do things perfectly we
have to do them with the best intent
which I believe we do but things are
going to go perfectly and guess what
some people are gonna be mad when you
make those mistakes some people are
gonna be mad even when you do things
right they're gonna look at you and say
oh you should have done that that was
the wrong thing to do okay here's what
we weighed out and you've got to be
willing to take those criticisms
leadership leadership is a very hard
thing so what do you make of the guy in
the White House now related to
leadership because even if we were just
to look at Iraq so it's like all right
George W Bush got us into Iraq
you can argue whether that was good or
bad or whatever Obama got us out and as
you just laid out maybe the way we got
out was probably not the right way to do
it it doesn't seem that from at least
what I could tell that Trump is looking
to get us into extra Wars or anything
that well it certainly doesn't seem like
he's looking to get us into any extra
worse I would agree with that and again
there's I don't believe that hey we're
gonna be an isolationist nation and
we're not gonna play on the world stage
I don't think that's the best thing the
other end of the spectrum is hey we're
gonna go fight and police up the world
that's not the right thing either the
right thing is to look at each situation
as it unfolds in the world and make try
and make the best decisions you can as a
leader at that time and and again these
are not easy decisions to make these are
these are decisions that that you make
them and they still unfold the day after
you make a decision the minute after you
make a decisions things unfold that you
didn't expect that you didn't anticipate
and yet you made a decision so now
you've got to make another decision and
and it's it's a challenge what do you
make of him just as a leader if we were
looking at the gray the way you would
grade a leader how would you look at
Trump from a leadership perspective yeah
I think Trump is an interesting
characteristic of some really broad
extremes right so he does things that I
say oh good move and then literally 20
minutes later 20 minutes later I'll be
thinking myself what what how can you
even think that this is a decent thing
to do right and and by that I mean you
know jumping out on Twitter and
criticizing some kind of person some
some individual human celebrity or
celebrity yeah hey what are you doing
why are you doing that you know so I
think the guy who was it that just you
the the the testimony that just took
place Michael Cohen yeah so Michael
Cohen gets up and says that Trump is a
bad character and I'm like okay you know
I mean this is this to me is not a
surprise I don't think this is a big
surprise anyone yeah this is not this is
a guy that he's not the guy that you
want your daughter to marry at least
least I don't want my daughters to marry
someone like that
okay so what's this character like not
the one that we want to model ourselves
after do we want do we expect do we want
a leader to be someone that we can look
up to and model ourselves after
absolutely absolutely we want to look at
a look at our leader and say wow I
really respect that person and I want to
follow them and I'm gonna emulate their
their actions and their behavior that's
that's absolutely that's what a leader
is yeah so does Trump fall short on that
oh yes he does oh yes he does so it's a
it's a strange world that we live in
that that guy versus Hillary Clinton who
he ran against neither one of those
people are people that that you look at
and say seems that could seems like a
character I want to emulate that's what
I'm looking towards I want to be that
person I want to I want to move in that
direction you know from the 300 plus
million people in America those are the
two candidates that we put forward what
is wrong with us yeah that's a problem
well what is wrong with us what do you
think the answer to that is is that just
the way the political system set up or
is that the media or is that us is it I
think it was a political system for sure
I think it has to do with the the way
that the way that media is and the way
she celebrity is that the the name is
able to carry itself the character that
Britnie self branding that goes out I
think drives so much of this that we're
not really we're not really assessing
what type of leader this person is going
to be we're assessing how popular they
are so for a guy that talks about
discipline a lot when you see Trump
tweeting is that what's going on in your
head you're like man this is just a
discipline thing like you get some of
these things right and if you could just
discipline yourself in another way yeah
I would say that I thought when when
Trump won the election and I was just as
surprised as anyone when Trump won the
election I thought okay well you know
what at least now we're gonna get to see
him step up an act presidential all that
what did it take 15 minutes before you
looked at it said okay guess okay it's
gonna take him a little bit longer than
I thought right but but it hasn't
changed and it was the same thing you
see Hillary Clinton do the same types of
things where you doing behavior that
you'd say yourself why are you doing
that
you don't do that you don't do those
kind of things you don't behave that way
and so I think you just have to you know
we have to kind of gut through I hope
that this is a situation where this is a
a point a pivot point for the country
where we'll start looking around and
saying okay we don't really want to do
that
uh-huh we want to look for the right
person that's gonna do this job
correctly that's gonna represent the
country well and are you worried that we
don't get out of this whatever this
thing is that everyone can sort of feel
and no one knows exactly what what it is
just this this endless bickering and how
it seems like social media is making us
all hate each other and you don't that
we don't have real at least at the
political level leaders to look up to if
you're looking for self-discipline and
morality and whatever you know what
people I had people write when Trump got
elected you know people would just fly
off the handle with me right and and I
don't really talk about politics very
often and the reason that I don't talk
about politics very often is because
well because from a leadership
perspective if I'm trying to get you to
do something the worst way to lead is
for me to bark at you and tell you what
to do mmm that's not good leadership so
I don't do that with people that I
communicate with I don't say hey he's
he's horrible and she's great or she's
horrible and he's gonna I don't say that
I just I just give examples from history
about the way good leaders behave and
the way bad leaders behave and let
people make their own decisions but
somebody was hitting me up hey you know
you need to you need to speak out and
you know I said okay well here's my
speech America is stronger than one man
America is stronger than one man America
is stronger than any one individual
politician we are we're a massive you
know massive ship and a massive ship
takes a long time to turn and the checks
and balances that are in place inside
the government which are sometimes
really really bureaucratic in and
disappointing and aggravating because
it's so hard to change things they're
they're hard to change for a reason so
am I worried that the
is that this tipping point won't come no
it'll come eventually because eventually
free people the free people of America
won't allow for things to go so far in
one direction it were so far in the
other direction we won't allow yeah now
what makes it hard to reach that tipping
point is because America it's so it's so
beautiful in America right there's
there's it's such a stress-free life
right it's just there's you know we were
in the middle of two wars and mmm that
didn't affect the average American in
any way whatsoever but not even the oil
prices like nothing affected them they
were still driving their SUV to
Starbucks and ordering a latte with zero
impact and that was when we were
fighting two wars and lete losing people
every day on those battlefields it was
no factor so what happens in America is
we where we pretty much don't care as
long as we're comfortable but if things
start to get uncomfortable that's what I
think the the real tipping point will
come and there'll be a backlash one way
or the other
yeah all right I want to shift off some
of the war stuff but very quickly so
since you mentioned the two wars the one
that nobody ever talks about or even
thinks about is Afghanistan which I
think now it's the it's the longest war
we've ever been in right I mean this is
the longest war it's still ongoing now
it seems to me that nobody knows really
why we're there or why this is so
ongoing what what the hell should we be
doing or thinking about or what it's
never discussed period yeah and it's
interesting because this is something
when when Trump if you remember Trump
said hey what's the plan and he got a
bunch of pushback and people were saying
oh who's he to ask and I was like well
he's the president and so yeah you need
some kind of a plan you need some kind
of a goal and I do think that needs
clear definition in Afghanistan of what
it is we're trying to make happen what
does that look like you know from my
perspective when you get into these
countries where you're trying to build
something or trying to you're not trying
to build yourself you're trying to allow
them to be free that's what you're
really trying to make happen you're
trying to allow these countries to be
free they're not going to be the same as
us that's one thing that I'm fairly
confident about there's different
culture
that are going to adopt freedom and
democracy in a different way and you
can't impose what we think it should be
like on other cultures because it
doesn't match up perfectly but it can
match up pretty well and individual
human beings in these countries you know
what they want they want a job they want
to build a little business they want to
be able to feed their kids they want
their kids to have a better opportunity
than they do that's what when you can
when you can provide some of that that
will start to take hold and when you
provide some of it other people in that
country will look out it goes hmm that
seems to be a pretty good deal over
there I would like to try that too and
pretty soon you can get freedom and
democracy the attitude of it to to
expand and so it takes a long time you
know the average counterinsurgency is
seven years but they can take really
really long time but in my opinion and
really through the history of the world
eventually in my mind eventually through
history eventually the free individual
will rise to the top and in and and they
will rule themselves and so you have to
give that opportunity for individual
freedom you they have to have the
opportunity to grow and to take root
take good solid root and to grow and be
strong enough that when tyranny comes
along it can't just wipe it out because
tyranny can wipe out the individuals
without probably we've seen that in
history - tyranny can wipe out and
destroy individual freedoms and
individual really individual aspirations
they can just be mopped up and destroyed
by tyranny so you have to give freedom
and individual freedom not just the time
to sprout up a little bit you got to
give it the time to take root because
once people have tasted true freedom and
true opportunity they don't give it up
and that's what I think you have to do
you have to
stay somewhere long enough that people
understand what true freedom is they
recognize that it's theirs to protect
and it has to be rooted strong enough
that it can't be white washed away by
tyranny so then going all the way back
so what what are we doing in Afghanistan
I mean do you sense that that's actually
happening there
because it's sighted something like 14
years or something yeah and it's one of
these things where we oscillate too much
on what it is that we're trying to
accomplish and what we're willing to
sacrifice to accomplish it because you
know from an isolationist perspective
from a from a okay let's just take up
America take care of America oh let's
take the Taliban oh you want to live in
like a world you want your country to be
you know back in the Stone Age and
that's how you want to live okay cool
we'll be over here doing our thing like
that's that's the yeah that's that's a
that's a legitimate plan hey you guys
want to live in the Stone Age cool we'll
be over here with iPhones that's fine
we don't care but then it's like okay
but we're gonna breed Terrace but okay
well we'll commenter cage me and knock
those guys out how's that okay we could
do that
and that's if that's the plan okay let
that be the plan what if we're gonna
stay there if we're gonna try and get
freedom to take group which I believe is
the best thing to do because I do
believe that we do have some level of
moral obligation to try and support
individual freedom throughout the world
that's that's to me that's pretty
self-evident does that mean that we have
to jump into everywhere that there's a
person no it doesn't mean we can't and
it also means that inside those
countries the human beings inside those
countries also has a moral obligation to
rise up and fight on their own and that
was nice about going back to Iraq was
you know I've got friends that fought in
Mosul as they took Mosul back but those
weren't Iraqi troops and we're moving
from building the building taking
massive casualties as a matter of fact
one of my friends that was there said
there was a in the beginning of the
Mosel campaign the Americans we're
located each other saying hey these guys
are taking so many casualties we're
gonna run out of Iraqi soldiers like
they're all gonna die and the Iraqi
soldiers continued to go forward and
they continued to fight and they ended
up you know getting the upper hand and
so when they say that that we were
greeted as liberators it actually is
true oh yeah yeah oh my god I mean in
Mosul oh it was and again I wasn't there
and I never fought in Afghanistan either
but the guys coming back from bosal
those the people were absolutely just
they were they were they were being I
mean everything enslaved beheaded
tortured everything it was absolutely it
was heinous yeah it was it was it was a
heinous war crime across the board so
yeah absolutely
so we're all right we've done a lot sort
of out of our borders here but it's
interesting you mentioned that you know
in the mid we can be in the middle of
all of these Wars and yet we can still
get a latte and we can still pay no
attention to it and live our good lives
do you think there's a risk to our
freedom here because of that that we've
got it so freaking good that we almost
don't know what freedom is anymore do I
think it's an actual risk no no I don't
I think that the minute things the
minute you start really talking about
taking away the personal freedoms of
Americans there will be real problems so
okay the is that a risk sure that could
that could be a risk I see that as a
real small chance that things get bad
enough where where mass groups of
Americans say oh yeah we're not we're
not we're not we're not doing that you
just cross the line you know the the
American Revolution right oh you want to
raise tea taxes no actually we're gonna
find a war against you you're not
raising the tea taxes right that's could
it get to that point here sure but you
got to remember what's gonna be
sacrificed and you know that's one of
the coolest things about the American
Revolution is that people that fought it
were the people that actually had the
most to lose
the people that stood up so it would
take it would take a lot but I'm I I
don't I think it would take a lot to get
there I think it would take a lot to get
there and if it gets there that'll be
sad it'll be a sad day
I believe that freedom would prevail
alright let's let's shift all together
to sort of what you're doing now so
podcasting writing all that stuff having
these kind of conversations it's kind of
cool that that people are paying
attention to this stuff now isn't it
we're when you started doing the podcast
was that just sort of you were just
gonna throw it out there and see what
happens and see if oh wow people might
want to listen to long-form conversation
yeah I did a podcast with Tim Ferriss
and when he press stop on the recorder
he said you should do your own podcast
and I Joe Rogan heard it and got me on
so I was on Joe Rogan's podcast in the
middle of that podcast I'll run it said
you should have your own podcast so Tim
Ferriss and Joe Rogan tell you to have a
podcast did have a plaque can you listen
so I did and for me it's a it's a it's a
great medium I always when I grew up I
grew up listening to radio shows and so
I always liked listening to radio and
that's essentially what it is is radio
without commercials and I get to talk
about things that I'm interested in and
and again you know the the advice some
of the advice that I got when I started
off was like oh you need to have guests
all the time people are getting tired of
you don't don't talk about these dark
you know don't talk about these dark
violent things all you can't talk about
war all the time and you need to keep
them shorter and all this and I didn't
listen to anybody and my podcasts are
really long some of them are extremely
heavy and dark and talked about some of
the worst in fact I think we've covered
most of the really the worst things that
have unfolded on the planet and they're
long and I don't have a lot of guests
you know I do have guests but I don't
have a lot of guests so the interesting
thing is yes shockingly enough people
people listen to it and the connection
and the feedback is is awesome yeah how
do you think it's changed you by going
to all those dark places and talking
about all this stuff and and expressing
your ideas and all that well I've gotten
I've gotten a lot I've gotten a lot of
experience out of it the experience I
get out of it is I so I do a lot of book
cover a lot of historical books like I
said first-person accounts of war and
atrocity in that
when I first started the podcast I said
well you know I probably got I'll
probably do five because I got like five
books that really had an impact on me so
I'll cover those books and then whatever
that'll probably it and then I said you
know there was one more book that I
really want to throw in this pile and
there was another one any what didn't
take but you know five or six more
podcasts where I said I'm never gonna be
able to do enough podcast to cover the
things that I want to talk about and
that's the way it's been so I've read I
read basically a book a week for the
last three years and you know I I I
finished doing all the books that I that
I actually you had already read yeah I'm
like I'm in like I don't know so you're
like I better write some then yeah well
I'd already written on my first book
when the podcast came out uh-huh
so so how has it changed me and the
other the other great thing is I get to
interact with all these people and
people come up and I know they do this
to you - people come up to me and they
say I know I feel like I know it's weird
but I feel like you know me and I'm like
yeah you do know me because how I am on
the podcast is actually how I am that's
just me and and then I tell them that I
actually know them too because if
they've listened to me for 500 hours
yeah you haven't spent 500 hours
listening to you know I mean it's like
that's just not happening
yeah so I do know them and then they
gave great feedback and I've learned a
lot from from the books that I read from
the people that I have had on and from
the feedback that I get and hey read
this book look at this aspect so it's
made me it's made me learn a lot so from
first person war books and all your life
experience how do we end up with we got
two of them here I think yeah
children's books yeah yeah yeah right
here well so there's the dragon yeah
yeah I might say dragon so yeah yeah I
didn't I didn't write I didn't I didn't
I didn't give Jordan any credit for it
you know it's called Nike the Dragons
Jordan sorry yeah I got four kids and as
I
started continuing to hear back from
people that were listening to what I was
saying and the one I'd hear a lot is I
wish I had this when I was a kid I wish
I had this when I was a kid
and of course my answer would be like I
do too I wish I had the lessons from
extreme ownership when I was a kid I
wish I had the lessons from the
discipline goes freedom field manual I
was a kid
absolutely and growing up or watching my
own children grow up I just knew that
the things that I tried to impart on
them I figured I could put into stories
where I couldn't part those values onto
little kids and make their lives easier
and better and that's it so I started
writing them and it was surprising that
at the the response the response has
been you know people love him and you
know one of my favorite letters I've
gotten is I got this letter from this
guy who you know he's saying I'm 37
years old and I was drinking and I was
overweight and I was doing they hadn't
been promoted and I got all these
problems going on his life and he he
said then I read your book and I said
okay I'm gonna wake up a little bit
early okay I'm gonna start working out
okay I'm gonna stop complaining okay and
he went through his whole letter and how
now he had lost 52 pounds and he had
been promoted and he'd stopped drinking
and all this stuff and then the last
line said the book I read was the way of
the warrior kid which is you know aimed
at kids but the lessons in there are
completely universal and applied to your
whole life so it's been it's been great
and I get a lot of social media posts of
little kids studying flashcards because
you know the premise of the warrior kids
story is that there's a little kid who's
you can't do any pull-ups he doesn't
know how to swim he's getting picked on
by the school bully
Kenny Williamson and he doesn't know his
times tables and the last day of school
ends and he's all sad and then he
remembers that his uncle Jake is coming
to stay with him for the summer and his
uncle Jake was in the SEAL Teams so his
uncle Jay comes to stay and first day he
says hey you know what do you wanna do
tomorrow won't do something you want go
for a swim and the kid goes I know to
swim and I don't know how to goes you
know don't know my time sail was getting
picked on so the long call says look
these aren't problems we can solve all
these gets him into jujitsu classes
teach
how to swim teaches them how to study
using flashcards and other members Asian
techniques and teaches how to eat right
teaches him to workout and the kid turns
turns around and so that's that one
Mikey the Dragons is about facing your
dragons and little kid that's scared of
everything
and he finds a book under his bed and it
opens it up quickly there's a bunch of
pictures in it that looks scary of
dragons and fire and so he doesn't want
to read it but there's also pictured in
there of a little kid that looks
confident and like he knows what he's
doing so he says alright you know I'm
gonna read this book and then you turn
the page in this book and you are now
looking at the cover of this next book
which is called the dragon prince and
that's the story of a kingdom where the
king had died and now there was no one
to defend the kingdom from the dragons
except for this little seven year old
prince and so he's scared he goes to get
his father's sword and his father's
shield opens up this big war chest and
in there he pulls out the sword it's too
heavy for him he pulls out the shield
it's too heavy for him he's even more
scared now and then he sees a note at
the bottom of the war chest and he pulls
it out and it's a note from his father
the king who explains to him what he
needs to do to stand up and face the
Dragons the story continues on so I
enjoy storytelling yeah well I sense I
sense an animated movie and I guess the
last thing I got free is what do you do
to relax after all this after all the
work and everything else and it's a
pretty intense life that you're living
yeah I'm guessing you're gonna say
working out but give me something else
well work does that include jujitsu
yeah well that's still within the
working out that thing but whatever
works for you that's you know I surf I
do do Jitsu I hang out with my kids play
guitar and yeah I find this stuff
relaxing it's enjoyable for me to to
write it's enjoyable for me to talk to
people about leadership and go out with
my company excellent front and teach and
align executives on leadership and watch
them be able to turn their company
around or bring their company to the
next level based 100% on leadership
which is what I tell them I say look
you've got this problem you've got that
problem you've got another problem every
problem that you have inside your
organization is lead
I guess that means you slayed the
dragons and you're doing the right thing
in life it's been a pleasure man we
finally were able to do this and for
more on Jaco you can follow them on
twitter at Jocko willing
[Music]